mine is the story of a man without a
plan I was an academic and pursued an
academic life then I became the Dean of
the University of where I worked then I
went into government accidentally and I
became the minister of development it
was called which included industry and
trade and development from there in
Venezuela in Venezuela
and from there I became I went to the
board of directors of the World Bank in
Washington where I it was quite an
experience
then I became a member of a think-tank
the Carnegie Endowment many years ago
and I was doing what people in
think-tanks do which is write and
comment then I became the editor of a
magazine called foreign policy then I
did that for 14 years and after that I
became a columnist and now I do also I
do all of that I write columns that are
published around the world I write books
and I do a lot of television programs
since as the career that I descried
great created many opportunities for me
to observe power up front closely and
sometimes experience it when I was in
government and and I always was
fascinated by the gap between what
people thought was the power of someone
in a cabinet position the minister and
the actual power that I had at the time
and I thought that that was because of
my main experience I was very young or
because my country Venezuela was very
dysfunctional and very weak in terms of
the state structures but then I stopped
started talking first to my colleagues
and they all felt the same way
then I had the opportunity when I was at
the World Bank to talk with a lot of
leaders from up
variety of countries in Eurasia and
Africa in Asia rest of Latin America and
I would probe that and I would discover
that many felt the same way as I did
that there was a power was becoming very
hard to to obtain to use and very easy
to lose and so I then started looking at
it more carefully then I was the editor
of foreign policy magazine for more than
a decade and as the editor of that
magazine that also put me in touch with
a lot of people with partner also with a
lot of people studying and understanding
and and viewing what was happening so I
started writing about it and so I wrote
the end of power that in many ways that
title is a misnomer I'm not saying that
power has ended and the world doesn't
have pockets of power highly
concentrated the Pentagon and the
Vatican the Chinese Communist Party and
the Kremlin and Google and Facebook and
Goldman Sachs or Exxon Mobil these are
centers institutions and individuals
that have a lot of power so my point is
different my point is that in the 21st
century power has become easier to
acquire harder to use and easier to lose
so it's happening everywhere it's
happening in Italy which in questell and
Battaglia
it's happening in Spain with podemos
it's happening in Europe where you have
all kinds of new parties coming out of
nowhere you can see in Poland and you
could see it in Hungary and elsewhere in
Asia in Latin America of course what do
they have in common well these are what
I call them micro powers they come out
of nowhere they have been probable
origins they have people at different
beginning
disdain them and give them no chance of
winning and then they are able to
displace what I call the mega players
the traditional power structures that
have dominated this the political scene
flow for a long time and so these
newcomers
but my point is wider than that because
I say and I think it I can prove that
this is happening not just in the realm
of politics is also happening in in the
area of war of business of media of
communications of art and culture and
science whatever there is human activity
organized human activity and therefore
power matters you will see that power is
becoming far more feeble and more
constrained but also easier to acquire
so from that perspective people have no
power if I'm right it are very
constrained in the way they can use it
and we are already seeing it in the case
of Trump he came with a wide agenda of
things that he was going to do
immediately and while we are seeing how
he is not been able to do much and how
he's going to is facing already a lot of
upheaval around his presidency what will
happen there is gonna differ from place
to place in doing so places Anarchy will
be common and they will have a very
frequent turnover of who is in power but
in other places we're gonna see
political innovations of the good kind
if you think about it we live surrounded
by innovations in all aspects of our
lives except in the way we govern
ourselves so innovation is everywhere
but we still pick our leaders and and
govern ourselves and monitor the
government and accountability and and
and participation and how to organize
different interests and how to work in a
democracy are still done in the same way
that they were done a hundred years ago
so I predict that there is gonna we are
at the verge of a wave of political
innovation that is going to be very
positive in some places in other places
there will be political innovation of a
horrible kind
will there be new revolutions given the
culture of mistrust it's easy to predict
that because it's already happening give
me the name of a country where people
are not in the streets people are in the
streets everywhere people are protesting
for a variety of things either because
they belong to the middle class of
countries like the United States and
Europe
that feels embattled and threatened and
under siege or because they belong to
the new middle class in India and Mexico
in Indonesia and Turkey and China
the new middle class that now has
expectations that has been empowered
that is better educated that is more
connected they are also taking to the
streets for different reasons but around
the world people are protesting because
political parties are no longer
providing them the channels to
articulate to organize to express the
grievances and their aspirations